hi we should be under America's team the
Lions what no the Cowboys oh yes welcome
to the par party it's pretty bright can
I get some protection no now remember
you're not supposed to blow
it we're here because we lost three in a
row you see parity means there's little
difference between the equality of these
teams do I have to do everything not my
first tea party there's been a mistake
we're um kind of a tear up from these
lower class teams your finger sandwiches
woo not the first finger I've eaten
won't be the last
but there's nothing better than parody
just ask the NFC South so then they got
rid of him and went with
me why are you here you only have two
losses yes but we're the Jags and God's
plan is for us to just be okay what a
treat to share all these Zach snacks
y'all yes even you the disgusting
distraction from the brown we tried the
whole being Elite thing but it was just
so hard toity Roger we don't pay you 65
million a year to be treated like this
I'm sorry how much much get the
mid-season Replacements dagy run not
really our strong suit this year Mr
Jones wait who are you
guys Walker I don't know oh thank God
the bills you can't fall short of
expectations if there aren't any a sweet
baby M even the BS are just okay
par tagy
stop is that Jesus Christ close this
jilling hurts take my
hand oops really should bend that
brotherly shove why Eagles
Why Alvin you know what I'm talking
about you're no stranger to a tussle oh
you're bad Taylor now I tell you what's
going on between a Lobby and car but I
don't think you're ready for that
te some don't I'll pay his F why the you
all talking like
that